the prime minister has made it clear
success in glasgow is a personal
priority but as talks enter a crucial
phase he must appeal for help from
others
so my
question
to my fellow world leaders this
afternoon as we enter the last hours of
cop is will you help us
do that will you help us
grasp that opportunity or will you stand
in the way
so there goes boris johnson to try and
inject
some energy ambition into the talks here
the collective efforts of more than 20
000 people at this summit have been
distilled effectively into this
four-page document it's clear from the
text this won't be the summit that
solves the climate crisis
but glasgow could yet go down in history
as the place where the plan to do that
lives or dies
the text is the first in the 30-year
history of this process to call for a
phase-out of coal and fossil fuel
subsidies
are you blocking the negotiation sir
phasing out oil and gas subsidies is
known to be a red line for states like
saudi arabia though they deny their
blocking progress
these are not fabricated allegations
they are fabricated allegations
it's thought talks could progress even
against saudi's wishes
but not so china can its special envoy
xi xinhua accept a plan that phases out
coal could i ask about coal is the is
the reference to coal in the text of
phasing out coal is this going to be a
problem for china
the text lacks strong commitments on
money for poor countries
who will be needed to help keep those
words in the agreement they have
actually been mean with cash and they're
mean with technology and so it's hard to
see how we can allow the vulnerables
contribute to help solve a problem
largely created by the rich minority
without the finance and without the
technology
no country will reveal all its cards
early in the negotiations
but should the rules of normal diplomacy
apply
so i'm saying to the leaders who are
here now this is on your watch
sorry
it's so important
you know
we are literally talking about
having a safe future
it looks certain even at this stage
there's been progress at this summit
but success can only be measured against
the physical realities of a fast
changing climate
tom clark sky news glasgow